[Music]
hi I'm Hannah Dickinson and this is
cheers to you cheers to you Japanese
princess for renouncing your royal
status to marry a commoner but upholding
the world tradition of women dating down
Cheers you sarah silverman for letting
louis c.k masturbate in front of you I
cannot wait for that remake of a star is
born cheers to you Congress for trying
to require more legroom on commercial
flights way to make more like space for
all those allegations cheers to you Oh
Jay Simpson for dressing as a
gynecologist for Halloween oh look
another bloody glove cheers to you woman
who stuck a kinder egg up her hoo-ha I
don't know how you did that all of my
chocolate pulls out and then deletes me
from their contacts cheers to you Canada
for introducing hot dog water it's
literally a hot dog soaked in water
it's $38 at a Canadian Music Festival or
free at a Las Vegas day club cheers to
you Burger King for offering a deal of
buying a whopper and getting a dog treat
for free in other words two whoppers I
love dog food dog treats are like pretty
good haven't you ever been in line at
Petco like I'll try it
cheers to you uber for developing
artificial intelligence to detect drunk
passengers it's a long way to go to find
white girls and tube tops yelling Greg
that's me cheers to you GOP congressman
for getting back into baseball practice
now you can finally take a swing at
something other than my reproductive
rights share see you IHOP for flipping
your name too i hob I for one won't be
getting what I always do when I
drunkenly go there diarrhea cheers to
you for tonight for bringing over a
billion dollars for those of you who
don't play for a night it's a video game
where you build forts for those of you
who do play a dollar is something you'll
earn when you finally get a job cheers
to you Matt Lauer for losing your horse
farm in your divorce settlement if only
you had a way to lock that gate cheers
to you Dane Cook for dating a girl who's
26 years younger than you I had no idea
you still had money cheers to you Colton
Underwood oh for being the next Bachelor
now you can cut down woman
one by one just like you were cut from
four NFL teams
cheers to Elon Musk for your child size
submarine that was rejected by the Thai
government they said it was not
practical for this mission which is
exactly what women say about your penis
cheers for you Tiffany Trump for
celebrating pride it's good to see you
acknowledge your father's penis all in
the ass
cheers to you stormy Daniels on the
details of trumps toad Weiner it's like
how else would I know that besides just
looking at him cheers to you Kylie
Jenner for trying milk with cereal for
the first time ever way to finally make
use of that silver spoon in your mouth
and also cheers to my hotel pool for
being the only thing to get me wet
thanks a lot cheers to you Ed Sheeran
for being wildly underdressed seeing
next to Beyonce
it's almost like she's better than you
hmm to be fair ed Sheeran would look
under a dress next to a plate of romaine
[Laughter]
cheers to you one out of 50 airplane
passengers who find love on an airplane
the statistic would be higher if anyone
would love me back
cheers to you nicole kidman for
revealing that your marriage to Tom
Cruise saved you from sexual harassment
that's the beauty of sleeping with gay
men no matter how much I drink I never
wake up sore ooh cheers to you Black
Friday for being created to promote
holiday shopping with great big sales
that make white women wet why do you
think they call it Black Friday cheers
to you Facebook for creating a pop-up
store it'll be filled with items you
mentioned to your friend one time over
the phone
how convenient oh my god this store
sells vibrators and pepto-bismol welp
that's it for cheers to you be sure to
check out our regular show every day I'm
day where this week I drink 100 bottle
salt doll your bottle dollar $100 bottle
of wine and we watch the best clips from
the Chappelle show why can't I speak do
I have a speech impediment or am i drunk
we don't know
[Music]